[Music]
one of the issues we haven't Gove into
too deeply around here is gun control
the contentious often venomous debate
about guns has been part of some of the
conversations we've had here on the
Rubin report especially when talking
about limited government constitutional
authority states rights and even freedom
of speech but it rarely has been the
focus of those conversations itself
interestingly gun control is one of the
issues that I get the most emails about
with people usually asking me my
personal feelings about the Second
Amendment and whether I believe in a
right to bear arms you're not going to
believe this but I do think that there's
a same middle ground that we can find in
the gun discussion that falls somewhere
between everyone should own a bazooka
and nobody should be able to have a
handgun first of all very clearly
without reservation I am a supporter of
the Second Amendment the Second
Amendment specifically states quote a
well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free State the
right of the people to keep and bear
Arms shall not be infringed end quote
this is interesting wording because it
guarantees the right of a citizen to
protect themselves from both other
citizens and the state itself by having
the ability to own a gun the guaranteed
a life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness which is enshrined in the
Declaration of Independence isn't only
for the government to ensure for you
actually it's quite the reverse it's
incumbent on you to protect your life
your liberty and your pursuit of
happiness even from the government if
need be in many ways this is the essence
of individualism while the state and the
government are an important facilitator
of our rights it's ultimately up to us
the individual to make sure we are truly
protected from people and governments
who would take those rights away as I
often say however two things can be true
at once while having a populace that can
defend itself is important at the same
time there really is little doubt to me
that we have a gun problem in America
whether we're talking about school
shootings which happen all too often or
assassinations of police officers has
happened in Dallas last year there can
be no doubt that the gun is the weapon
of choice when someone wants to
indiscriminately kill as many people
as possible I should pause and separate
mass shootings from terrorism
specifically where terrorists usually
use some sort of explosive to kill as
many people as possible although
recently we've seen guns knives and even
cars and trucks thrown into the mix and
it's also important to remember that the
weapon itself doesn't make the
distinction between a criminal act or
terrorism
it's the ideology behind the act that
does that the fact that there are many
ways to kill people though does bring up
an interesting idea about guns if I had
an assault rifle or any other gun I
wouldn't go into a school or church or
anywhere else and randomly kill people
likewise I've got some pretty great
kitchen knives right down the hallway
here and I don't go into mosques or
temples and stab anyone this shows that
the gun itself is just the tool and the
issue around gun control is much deeper
we should be having an honest
conversation about issues like mental
health the overuse and side effects of
prescription drugs the insidious nature
of evil ideologies the access to guns
that mentally unstable people have and
much more
unfortunately we only seem to have these
conversations at the worst possible
times usually right after another
shooting this gets the anti-gun crowd in
a frenzy to take away all guns and it
gets the pro-gun crowd to think that the
government is going to come to their
house and take away their guns don't
believe me well just check how gun sales
skyrocketed under President Obama but
have now dipped under President Trump
all of these issues are just the tip of
the iceberg when it comes to guns I
think that there are good people on both
sides of the debate who just see a
different solution partly because they
are seeing a different problem in the
first place some see this truly is a
problem with guns themselves while some
see this as a larger societal problem
with mental health but perhaps just
perhaps there's merit to both arguments
joining me today to unpack this highly
charged discussion is Antonia Okafor
Antonia is a Second Amendment
advocate who spends most of her energy
pushing for legislation to allow women
to carry guns on college campuses as a
young black conservative she's found
herself on the outside of what the
mainstream says someone who looks like
her should believe
you will talk about her political
evolution from an obama voter to a trump
supporter and why she thinks that a
woman's right to defend herself by
herself is so important without the
reactionary hysteria were usually caught
up in when discussing guns can the two
of us find some common ground well
there's only one way to find out
[Music]
joining me today is a second amendment
advocate the founder of empowered a
movement of women on college campuses to
feel empowered when they use their guns
for self-defense and a woman who is
black armed and conservatives Antonio
before welcome to the Rubin report thank
you thank you for having me
black hair armed and conservative heads
are exploding right now I know that
rippling across the internet oh yeah oh
yeah I'm sure that that's why I love it
that's right intentional you're a rabble
rouser yeah you're going right at it
last time a conservative I got that
right off your website yes what it says
yes that really I mean it must make
people crazy just when they just see
that the amount of judgement you must
get must be off the charts right yeah
well in this day and age this to be any
three of them especially together any
combination it makes people upset of
course you know anything makes makes you
focus on these days especially that I
mean maybe blacks armed and liberal
blacks armed and leftist but black
farming and conservative forget about it
yes you serve it with that that's the
one that probably people get most
annoyed at it probably is and I've had
people tell me well you kind of alienate
people by saying it's cuz you're
conservative like well what I'm going to
say will live it to make it easy for you
to you know to digest
I mean I'm conservative you know what
people know about conservatism is that
there is a social conservative and then
as the fiscal conservative and you
contemplated that but yeah I don't think
in this day and age people don't like
that word and they assume different
things and you say conservatives alright
so we're gonna get to some of your
conservative yeah yeah and we're going
to get to some of the guns stuff yeah
and I guess we get to some of the black
stuff that too but let's just tell me a
little bit about yourself you grew up in
Dallas Texas girl I am do still live
there now right tell me a little bit
about about growing up were you always
you're always laughing yeah I was always
why I will say that that
well in this day and age again you can
see it you can change it a a blonde hair
blue eyed girl can tell her tell someone
that she is black not a Blackfoot
Nigerian now which I'm really upset
because my parents are from Nigeria so
wait is that right not only can you be
this absurd thing which is transracial
which is white people now saying yeah
well you can actually pick a nationality
well Rachel how their last name oh yeah
those she chose a black last Nigerian
last name and it was funny because that
same week that happened was when blogs
Twitter attacked me and apparently some
blogs that were nigerian american blogs
that were upset with me and called me
they said that I was a disgrace Nigerian
name the same time they're praising that
which is why people that's white woman
that decides that she's gonna be it at
night in June 19 American and therefore
she's she has more praise than I do
yeah that's the world we're in right now
are very a couple women why were they
upset at you there because I was general
assessment but it was cuz I took a
picture with Tommy Lehren how dare this
yeah a disgrace to the black name but
especially to Nigerian name I was like
you know I'm a Nigerian so therefore why
now be the only way to be just to
actually the straight line during name
is if you're not a doctor a lawyer or
engineer
oh I'm really sure you're all set
so yeah that's what intolerance I by
association and you're friends with
Tommy and you have done stuff on the
blaze and all that and that guilt though
it's interesting to me because just
maybe two or three months ago when Tommy
was on real time I was in the audience
that night and I took a picture at the
after-party with Tommy and I had a nice
chat with her and then I took a picture
with Bill and I had a nice chat with him
and it was I didn't see anyone on the
right that was attacking me for taking a
picture of Bill there I gotta like deal
whatever but I got a ton of hate from
people on the left for talking to Tommy
and that sort of disconnect like the
hatred isn't even on both sides at the
moment I don't know and it's I mean yeah
how many times I mean only thing why
they knew about that is because Tommy
retweeted my picture with her and she
had me on her show to talk about
empowered and I was real
grateful for that but it's really not
the sad part is says okay what Agartha
gars you believe heard or agree with her
or not I mean just because you're
literally on a show with someone which
that's usually the premise is that you
bring people of different viewpoints and
perspectives and you talk about it
that's interesting Peavy but that's not
tolerated anymore to be associating with
someone I mean I just think as a black
person though the reverse racism which
is on reverse racism what's it's called
what it is it's racism because the fact
that she's a blond-haired blue-eyed girl
and I'm a black woman therefore we
shouldn't associate especially because
she doesn't have the same ideology as a
black person should have right she
should have yes but I should have right
which in an odd way that is prejudice in
itself that prejudging I'm only going to
hear what you tell me over the next hour
that's only the way I'm going to judge
you not by any other absolutely
absolutely I mean Martin Luther King I
really believe would be rolling on this
over in her grave right now the fact
that his speech talking about the
content of your character not to call
your skin have been flipped around these
days to to really be to verify their
agenda the people on the radical left
agenda and and perpetuate what
narratives they have which is absolutely
the opposite of what he wanted for this
country and in the future of his
children like he said yeah all right so
let's back up for a second so just tell
me a little bit about growing up with
yeah Emily conservative that black as it
is twenty years ago yeah you know what
well I'm going to I'm going to drop some
knowledge there are a lot of if anything
I would say the majority of why people
are conservatives that this is a radical
notion for me to say that but I really
believe it I believe my parents are very
conservative I mean I grew up with their
values and their values are they out of
my business I want to have a small
business because I this is how I'm able
to make a living here in America
I believe the American dream education
is how you're going to prosper you are
responsible for your own paths and life
and you make that decision all those I
mean even if you go on the social side
being pro-life etc what have you all of
those notions and values I received my
family but yet they are they voted for
Hillary and Bernie last time make it out
discuss this concept with a couple
people yeah yeah what's the disconnect
there then you know what I see to be
honest completely is that my mom will
talk about how the values that she has
but in the end she'll say oh but
Republicans are racist
oh but considered as a racist it's it's
a calmness effective tool to to really
divide the same values to say don't go
on that side because those people don't
like you they don't like you they don't
like you they hate you because of your
skin color because your sexual
orientation because of who you are as a
person and not the values that you have
and it's sad because I have to deal with
that every day with my manly that's
interesting so you're dealing with that
but how much actual racism are you
dealing with from on the right because
for example just yesterday you were at
you shot a video with Prager you that I
think in a couple weeks I did something
with Prager you I got a lot of hate from
people on the lesson how could you work
with right-wing Prager and blah blah
blah and all give us all the usual stuff
you may now get it from the black
communities and how could you work with
someone on the right even though they
know you're conservative and but how
much actual racism do you experience
from the right I don't see you know I
will be honest there have been the very
those people who will call Michelle
Obama but you know seriously this has
happened which will call Michelle Obama
and a person like that that is I mean
regard and I don't know if they're
really conservative or not I mean
they'll act like they are but they might
have other Democrat last time it really
I see as a people thing
not a biology especially conservatives
and conservatism is an ideology and you
need to know your stuff to know if you
really are conservative when we see this
in this day of populism and Trump
conservative conservatism does not mean
Republican not mean libertarianism
sometimes so of course you see that I'm
not going to say there's not racism out
there on the other side but yeah I've
always felt comfortable and that's the
thing is that most people are not going
to get their little bubble and talk to
people that don't look like them even
more so not think like them that's so
rare these days and that's sad and 2017
that were going backwards yeah bad I
mean we do feel like we're going
backwards and it's interesting I've
mentioned this before but when I get
invited to colleges I'm only invited now
by the Young Republicans the
libertarians of tomorrow the phandom
people the Liberty this look at that
even though by most accounts gay married
their choice for you know I'm against
the death penalty on for having some
sort of safety net like all of these
things and yet I don't get invited by
anyone on the left so it's like where is
the tolerance again exactly and I'm
still waiting I would love to tell
someone she's like you know what we love
your views on everything else except for
the guns but you know come out but you
would individually their own games with
them you would show tolerance if a group
on the left was like you know we're just
going to hear a different view from a
black woman yeah you know to me just to
play their little identity politics
thing exactly the identity politics
which you know I was sick of and you
know I voted for Obama twice of
twenty-eight in 2008 and 2012 but I
still haven't well I really started to
get the identity politics part of it the
victimhood mentality part of it and I
really wanted a difference I realized it
was something different out there for me
that was Rand Paul and I got really
involved quickly with the Rand Paul
campaign and because criminal justice
reform it's still something very
important to me and my father went to
prison when I was five years old for
mandatory minimums in a drug
and I'm different for most conservatives
and that I push for criminal justice
reform and and I'm vocal when anybody on
the Republican side tries to you know
squelch any type of reform there and
unfortunately we're gonna seem a little
more with you know Jeff Sessions and his
mandatory minimum bringing that back
again and I'd be something to reform the
prison system and make it more
functional and more economically viable
exactly those all should be Republican
appellees are conservative yeah exactly
fiscal conservative even if you just
come look at that I'm even hearing about
people just on the money exactly I was
like okay you could like this don't talk
about the fact that you don't really
care about people but on the money let's
talk about the money in the business
person you're saving so much so that's
why I mean look to a Rick Perry in Texas
who you know do I think that he's his
big Pro criminal justice reform advocate
now I mean I just think you the
businessman he brought a lot of business
back to Texas but he also brought a lot
of savings when it came to the prison
reform stuff that he did there yeah does
that kind of show that it doesn't matter
sort of necessarily what intentions are
all the time I mean like yeah he doesn't
care at the personal side which would
sort of be upsetting at some level but
if you doing the right thing because you
doing something for fiscal reasons
that's still at the end of the day we're
making it so when when and but there's
still people unfortunately am all three
on the minority but a vocal minority
within the Republican Party not you know
I change from being a Democrat to
Republican and part of that because I
realize I am a conservative and that's
kind of why I went more on the Rand Paul
side because you know he is very he's I
would say and he had said before he's a
fiscal conservative first and that's
what I saw as a young person in college
realizing that here I vote for this man
Obama and he has Obamacare and that's in
the backs of me and my generation and
then I see that the economy really still
sucks unlike what NPR says Amy Arquette
telling me this whole time a four years
of in college that big home was great so
it didn't I wasn't very good at your old
man
oh man for you hey I'm a turkey burger
yeah I'm on the Community Advisory Board
except you care to go so just cut that
up no I'm going to be honest and you
know that's what I heard all the time is
that you know Obama did so much for not
only young people but for white people
and I didn't see I didn't see the stacks
for this that's for that but that wasn't
proven and so that's when I started to
realize the fiscal side especially I was
very passionate about why are we 20
trillion dollars in debt and that is
okay we just have these blinders on and
it's going to be in the backs of me and
my kids and people are not saying up for
students and from and for Millennials
and that's kind of why I got more into
the campus carry movement as well
because that's another movement where
students were kind of felt like there
were second-class citizens for a long
time yeah so we're going to dive deep
into that yeah I'm a little bit shy
against or cocky right now I mean I saw
ya Elway I was thinking that's the best
place this is the best ways not to get
in trouble
yeah what makes you define yourself or
use the label conservative as opposed to
libertarian because a lot of the stuff
and we talked about Rand Paul yeah real
libertarian stuff do you see a
difference or is it just split hairs or
you know I think in the tests and
everything that I'm so libertarian
that's ideology wise I am I just feel
like I'm in this weird especially in
this age of Trump or populism or
whatever where people are trying to
figure out well and I saw especially
during the election with Austin Peterson
and stuff like that where these
conservatives who were Republican Party
but they were more conservative and they
wanted a place they wanted a home base
but they didn't really find it in either
and so I say conservative because
literally I mean libertarianism
if as long as you don't believe that
it's force that makes that value you can
be a liberal or you can be conservative
but the difference is there's one half
force or not right and so I think that's
why I consider myself a small L
libertarian but really I'm conservative
when it comes to
schools and searches and quite a bit
social conservatism I feel as well so
like what kind of social probably the
most is my pro-life stance that you know
I've been always in pro-life even while
as a Democrat and I think that's all
saying is that a lot of people in
minority communities Hispanics blacks
their their conservative in those values
and those traditional values but they
still just something about the
Republican Party doesn't fit well they
don't know about the Libertarian Party
yet so when you hear so for example as
someone that's pro-life when you hear
the media will say well you know if if
we take away funding from Planned
Parenthood or we have any other rules or
regulations around abortion or whatever
it is that that's going to hurt minority
communities most you don't even think
that that that that notion is coming
from the communities themselves oh no
they just let me tell you a story though
2012 I go to this woman for Obama
luncheon and you know I'm there I'm
excited yeah 2012 another another four
years for Obama and the the head girls
while there's a small Business Coalition
behind me and is mostly a box chimeric
and women and they literally ask the the
head person there that day so I'm not
sharing much about the African American
community you can are you going to be
doing any other than any plans for you
guys to be reaching out to them and the
woman literally tell them that well we
already got we got 95% of the vote last
time we don't really need to focus on
them well there's sort of a refreshing
candor there yeah but I'm pretty sure
didn't know why she was and all sort of
us look at each other I remember and
we're just like what your point yeah
like did she don't say that she knows
what she just said and it was then I
started to think you know what they
think they have in the bag I mean yeah
so that was really your light bulb that
was like wow I'm in played this whole
time we can play this whole time you're
right it's 95 percent of us are voting
this the same way worse is any other
group that doesn't and I mean even the
Hispanic community tends to you know
they're buried every election that you
don't know exactly but yeah they can I
think they have it in the bag every time
and they take those people
for granted and that's when I started to
realize is he really doing stuff about
community has poverty level has gone
down since then as welfare GaN Dom since
then are we more dependent on the
government since he's been president
yeah we have that so shown that and I
continue to do my research and that's
the thing is a lot of people will not do
the research and don't know your history
they don't know you know which I'll talk
about later but you know with black
people and guns that they've used that
to protect themselves against income
control groups like the KKK or their
history has been that a lot of them have
been conservative or Planned Parenthood
that that started as a way to and
basically you have a genocide of all
minorities in the first place a lot of
people not going to do the research on
that and so that's why I feel this I
don't say a burden but as a mission to
to use that to use my my knowledge of
that history and bring it out there and
say this is actually your history and
contradictory to what they're telling
you right now yeah and it's so
interesting to get people to think about
this stuff because you know when when
one of the police shootings happen in
Florida and everybody was talking about
well now ways to get rid of stand your
ground and even though I think we differ
a little bit on guns we can get to that
and that's great that I remember
thinking wait a minute
you're taking away stand your ground
which means that a black person who's
being attacked might be able to have a
gun and protect himself and yet they
always come in with with more ideas to
actually take the power away from the
people and also only in scared
yeah and I'll always use that one case
and sport of that woman she was
basically she kind of was a victim of
domestic abuse with her husband her her
husband was abusive and where she shot
in the air as a warning shoulder and she
got of a mandatory minimums or what ten
years or so I think more than that and I
think they change they dropped it later
on but they always go back to that case
we'll see see black people I mean that's
why guns are not for black people
because you know all this racism is
going to do the opposite instead of
standing your ground you're not going to
be able to actually protect yourself
without getting by without going to jail
or or having a gun without going to jail
or being prosecuted some some way so
they'll use that but they won't use them
many times that other people have used
it for self-defense
and have not had that case happen to
them I mean it's not about race it's
really it's really about poor log about
mandatory minimums let's talk about that
let's talk about the criminal justice
reform system let's stop making about
race every single time and then losing
the actual policies and issues that are
important which can actually change
everyone's out yeah when it comes to
that so when you had that light bulb
moment and you voted for Obama twice and
all this stuff and then you realize wow
they're there they're playing me how did
you start talking about this stuff
because I get a lot of people emailing
me and tweeting me and messaging me one
way or another talking about that
they've sort of had a wake up to a lot
of the things but I think people like us
are discussing but they're afraid to
talk about in there you know what I mean
if you're going again yeah whatever your
community might be or whatever your
family might have a me for any of that
stuff it's hard to do that right like
how did you start putting that into
motion oh man I think God just gave me a
little bit of I don't care and blue
isthmus to a little both so it will come
up and I remember for example my sister
just graduated a couple weeks ago and so
all my family came in and relatives
everywhere and that's Nigeria and
everything and my uncle of Nigeria had
just come he's a priest and my mom shows
him my NRA video the video that I did my
toque at their any convention and he
goes you voted for Trump and I'm just
like oh crap you don't know about that
and so I was like this whole we go here
we go again I thought I thought what's
that like right after he after he won so
it's like this continuous loop of I'm
never going to get away from this this
is going to be something that's going to
be a contentious issue but I'm not
afraid of that I'm not afraid that
because I used to beat them and I know
what it is to think that think that way
and I feel like it's I it makes it more
important for me to be that mediator and
to say look they're not
racists assign while you're watching on
MSNBC and all these great shows that
like to say what the right looks like
you liberal use of the word yeah great
so informative and newsworthy is so you
can cut we can add that part to if you
want to use it for others so that's an
adventure but I want to look really
liberal one day I've never heard yes
actually that's the moment to put in the
prologue well I know if you know that
you wouldn't bring some people more
people but but no would like to say that
those those shows are not giving them
this false idea of what it means to be a
conservative to be a libertarian I mean
and that's the thing is that they think
what Batarian sometimes think that big
and we're good no one no one don't
everybody really thinks that the races
are on the conservative side no they
think libertarians are also the same way
and they kind of put them in the same
bubble in the same you know pot if you
will but and I'm also there to say no
Rand Paul is great in fact look what
he's doing he's talking about criminal
justice reform he's or libertarians in
general they're talking about criminal
justice reform especially right now I
mean if you're going to go somewhere go
there look at what they're doing and
notice that you have more in common than
you think versus the other side I just
tells you that the only reason why you
should stay here is because the other
side is this boogeyman and you will not
be accepted so so when you use some of
the facts yeah some of the facts on this
stuff like for example and I've had
Larry elder here and he's talked about
that the cities that have the biggest
interesting problem with violence and
crime and all this stuff where the black
community is really struggling but the
cities usually have Democratic mayor's
yeah for decades
Atlanta and Chicago and Ferguson and all
of these places and then during the
election I kept seeing everywhere people
are blaming Trump for racism
yeah that's why it's like wait a minute
wait a minute he does nothing to do with
what's happened for 50 years in Atlanta
or all the killings in Chicago does he
say some crazy things absolutely but
that disconnect how are you able to when
you've been able to change minds how do
you do it
yeah and I love it because when I've
been able to change minds it's because
of
policy issue if it's not just you know
Millennials right now they'll talk about
how where we don't really want to be a
part of a party we just want to have an
issue-by-issue like we care about the
issues same thing I think what the
minority community is that if you can
get them on one thing that you think you
guys can both have in common has really
nothing to do with politics I think that
is a gateway to being able to get them
to change their mind on other issues but
some most people don't want that most
people just want you to agree with them
completely or I'm not talking to you
anymore like I'm blocking you on Twitter
and Facebook that's it never again I
can't reach the person you have to have
the patience and I have a not Wonder
Woman on you know it's just because my
family it's so personal to me and I know
what is at stake every single day that I
have that patience because it's that
important to me otherwise I I could just
leave I could just say I'm not going to
talk to you again I'm not going to do
that to my family I like framing it
around that because I think a lot of
people do feel that I'm growing up my
family was there always arguing about
politics and I have uncles that would
disagree with my mom and my dad would be
arguing this is here and this but we
were all family at the end like we would
argue and argue and argue for hours at
the table during holidays and then we
were all okay that seems to be
disappearing these days that and that
that's risky exactly I mean to have
dinner and having conversations on a
table period with your family these
phases is something that you don't see
so well I mean I can just move across to
across the country and not see my
families we have as argument then why do
I what I would I care really I mean yes
they're family but I can just toss them
on skype and it'd be good so we don't
have that much for libertarianism or
anything like that yeah so when I've had
people like Larry Algernon and a couple
other people when they've talked about
the breakdown of the black family this
seems like it's sort of very much in
line with what you're talking about
right there is some disconnect there
where they're replacing the family with
the state absolutely and and that's why
you're seeing it particularly in
minority communities I wouldn't even say
beset further particularly in black
families because you're not I mean over
40 percent of our households that we
grow up and I mean I didn't grow up with
a father growing you know growing up in
single mother is so
oh it's it's really what the example is
not the example in a good way but that's
what we see these days is particularly
the black family so if your family's
broken and and and you can't see that
family unit as something to trust and to
to want to build upon and want to you
know continue to develop then why would
you why would that be an important thing
to you especially if you think
differently I mean how many times I'm
just like oh whatever you're never going
to get it you vote for burning one okay
get out of here I can't deal with this
anymore but I love them and I wanted to
develop my family and my relationships
with them so I'm going to come back and
I'm going to deal with it every day
yeah how much you think the media also
has has sort of tricked up the black
community using phrases like that but no
god but yeah well like so for example
like with Oscars so white and we have to
have this many black people on this or
this many of any minority whatever it is
that it's really taking your eyes off
the prize the prize being you know work
hard we don't have to all be in
Hollywood and we don't know let's go get
a certain amount of Oscars to prove
acceptance we're like the Asian
community for example has worked very
hard at you know focus on education and
all those things and then we see that
they succeed economically and in all
sorts of other ways that you can you
know sort of measure these metrics yeah
do you think the media is sort of
intentionally doing that no our
community huh yeah and they've done a
good job of it for a long time and
that's I remember she said to clean when
I said okay I'm gonna identify I want to
come out of the closet I'm going to be
I'm going to say I'm conservative I'm
I'm going to vote Republican who who
knows I'm sure it's gonna be Rand Paul
who's going to be the Republican nominee
this is 2012
yeah or whoever is going to be and
thinking I'm going to do this despite
the image the current image that
Republicans and conservatives
libertarians house because I know the
effective messaging that the other side
has done so well that people literally
can are disqualified are the issues and
the values and things that actually
affect and are important to them and
they will they will discount it because
someone's race
because someone because someone said
they're racist or the sexist a
misogynist period yeah that's the fact
that we're in that state in America
where that really legitimately keeps
smart people from looking at the issues
is very dangerous and I think it's
important that people like me have come
from the left who have seen that and can
can call out that BS and say look I was
a part of that and I probably woke up to
the fact that there are so many bigger
things that are affecting me that I'm
not paying attention to a lot of you are
not paying attention to because they
literally think this other side is the
boogeyman and here we are we have more
more debt and we have more you know
people dying of poverty and becoming
socialists and and thinking that's okay
because because they literally think the
other person hates them as a person
they're doing a good job about that
they're doing a great job but it's up to
me and people like me to be able to tell
those people on the side that that's
that's wrong and bring attention to that
yeah it's nice to hear because we have
even though we come from very different
places we have sort of similar journeys
politically yeah where we're both trying
to wake up I think these are good
identical a lot of these people are good
people yes I think that a lot of them
the leaders say of the progressive
movement are not good but I think a lot
of the people are good and you just got
to wake them up with some ideas
absolutely and I think that's why it's
important that they do allow people like
us who think a little bit differently to
to comment to talk to these people
because I think there are a lot of
people who are real first audiological
don't care the honors I think they're a
pathetic regardless and so they're just
going to get their information from the
people that they trust and they think
are experts when they might not be same
thing on college campuses we look up
professors and academics could we think
that they should know everything and we
take their their word as God you know so
we have to wake up those people as well
to show hey you should be criticizing
everyone and everything that you hear
stop being forced by this this media and
this information be strict about what
type of information that you're taking
in
all right so we're gonna get the guns in
one second question legend Rand Paul a
couple times yeah I really like Rand
Paul May when I was watching the
Republican debate he struck me as pretty
much the only sane guy but my problem
with him was that it was as if he was on
a stage that he shouldn't have been on
that LAT form itself and when he was
talking about fiscal responsibility or
reining in the military or some of these
other libertarian things that you've
mentioned that it was like he would say
it would kind of make sense but then
nobody would even respond to it because
it was like yeah yeah it's that crazy
libertarian guy ultimately are you sort
of disappointed why I assume you're
disappointed that he didn't get the
nomination perhaps or that it didn't go
further but are you disappointed that he
hasn't just come out and said I'm a
libertarian I'm gonna run as a
libertarian even percent it and like
really get that movement to get going
man and that's that's the constant
debate always is that people are upset
because he's not libertarian he hasn't
claimed to be I mean also his dad dinner
to afterwards but for me though
especially coming from that side and
like Rand Paul was the I want to say
like he was a transition like he was the
one who made me start looking at wow
okay maybe there are things to these
values that they're talking about I'm
not going to look at everything else
because he for me I felt like he did the
worst that most people she was doing is
going into minority communities and
talking about those issues
I was very congratulated that he did
that first you know I think you know I'm
a small a libertarian at this point
depends on the nominee next time
probably get hate for that one but you
know I mean I was the I Lawson Peterson
was the nominee I probably would have
gone more that way for several reasons
but I think Rand Paul and I think I'm
really awesome we you know I've Adam
here we have this guy to run as a
libertarian I asked him it doesn't sound
now sound like maybe something in Utah
like a smaller that's why I'm here than
you Senate typing with room see also
he's like hi giveaway I'm pretty sure
you're not secretive about that but but
yeah what that
but that issue is that people are
wondering is it better to just be a
libertarian and the Republican Party or
be able just go all-out libertarian
party you know I'm innocent to say what
I've seen that I was actually worth is
kind of like what happened with the
health care reform bill just a couple
months ago where it was a freedom caucus
and the people like Thomas Massie and
Justin Amash the the small-l
libertarians in the Republican Party who
were actually able to convince people to
stop it
I think instances like that they are
more effective if they weren't there
that first bill would have been already
passed yeah so it's really just a
tactics thing exactly I at one level you
could be like yeah we need this
libertarian star to come out and really
fix the party and like be the leader
that Gary Johnson was and on the other
hand I totally hear what you're saying
like maybe it makes more sense to
maneuver from the inside of the existing
system and I guess that's just like yeah
I can help but you can have both though
we're kind of like and that's the thing
is that I can remember when during a
debate and he said and one that people
asked him well do you think Bolivian
party the small of the lotharian ISM is
going to continue in the Republican
Party and he said this was a moderator
for debate and he said Rand Paul said
well I think it's going to stay in the
Paul family that con rub me the wrong
way because like I don't think you guys
are the end-all be-all and I hope that
you guys all think that this is going to
be the case because we're the thing
about the libertarian Liberty movement
is that it's young but there's also a
lot of young bright stars in it so many
great people I mean with young emergence
for liberty and ending the people who
followed ran and even Ron Paul there are
so many people coming up and so the next
10 to 15 years who knows well finally
probably have those people the best
world who can fix the issues and be
principled but who can also you know
carry a great conversation and get
people to like them and be honest and
someone that they want to be President
so I don't think we're done an out yet
even with the Libertarian Party I think
there's a lot of good things to come in
the future we just have to learn from
our mistakes from the past are you ready
to talk to us oh yeah you're
I can walk through your day why so
you're not packing at the moment but now
you're obviously a huge defender of the
Second Amendment so was was the gun
piece of your political evolution with
that how much was that the whole thing
that you realized that you needed to be
able to defend yourself and you wanted
your community to be able to do that and
all that it was a big part but
definitely still the fiscal side was was
the transition part and that's why I
went to Rand at first but no the guns
became an issue for me basically because
it was so personal for me being on a
college campus you know the graduates
graduate student in 2015 and the campus
carry issue came about again it was I
was you know flabbergasted that it was
going for a third time in Texas of all
states and it was looking at it might
not pass again and I like the campus
carry yeah so campus carry is concealed
carry on college campuses so basically
for example Texas you're allowed to
conceal carry if you're over the age of
21 if you pass a mental health and a
criminal background check if you go
through all the processes you're
supposed to do then you're able to have
a gun on your person out of your house
so about campus carry is ringing that
that right we bringing a mat permit
holder and a will enabling them to be
able to use that same thing in a college
campus on a college campus and so maybe
that's what it does each College have
their own policy on that so it is that
what the fight is so the fly is state by
state that's how it was campus carry
so in Texas how what they pass the bill
was that every public university and now
Community College and starting August
1st of this year has to have some type
of of concealed carry on campus
legislation the difference they did on
that one last minute though was that
they added amendment saying that every
college gets to put a policies of where
gun free zones within that college would
be and so a lot of my work when I joined
soon for concealed carry when I was with
them was basically looking at every
College that was trying to because
they're obviously anti campus carry and
trying to null and void the whole bill
in general and making sure that they
weren't putting up these outrageous
policies where someone like me wouldn't
be able or wouldn't even want to carry
on campus will be so hard to write
finality they gave them the loss was
written in a way that gave them so much
leeway that they could create every
gun-free zone every way yeah and you'd
have to walk like you were doing amazed
and Zach exactly and that was the
intention and we fought against that and
so right now how it is right now a lot
of people are able to carry on campus
and Texas and Georgia just got the same
thing just a couple weeks ago the
concept of gun-free zones I find really
interesting because I see people on the
Left constantly screaming we need more
gun-free zone of gun-free zones I the
idea of that sounds fine on this level
but only the bad guys are going to break
the law to bring the gun there and then
you might need a gun take them out I
mean did I just blow your mind with that
right that was pretty well oh yeah I
know I know then come on those criminals
they have hearts too okay they can
change their mind right because not
really good mind could we change yeah
well you're looking like you look alike
women can I do it I don't know does free
zone sorry can't do it over there really
well yeah it sounds so idiotic no listen
what you feel about guns in general just
that weather where you want legalization
or states rights or any of that like the
very concept of this sounds just not
well I'm but but again the messaging is
that there are so people who believe it
and the thing about campus carry too is
what I learned with concealed carry on
campus is that it wasn't just the left
either the ones who are just blatantly
I'm anti-gun I want guns anywhere I say
that I don't like also in gun ban but I
really kind of do type people it's
really the people that I had to convince
the most for the people on the fence or
what we had to convince them else with
students concealed carry with them is
that those Republicans right even and
not just the Republican students or the
constituents but even the Republican
congressman and women who would say that
yeah I'm Pro Second Amendment and gun
should be for all people but on college
campuses so I don't know
don't students is something about
students on campus that it would for
some reason was okay to have gun-free
zones because maybe because it's an
extension of what we think about
students right now we're seeing UC
Berkeley students and we're like is that
the type of people we want with guns no
I don't agree but yeah exactly but so we
had convinced those type of people the
most particularly women and so that's
where I came in when I was able to talk
to those women and say hey you know what
the reason why I started fighting for
campus carry is because I want the
choice to be able to protect myself from
someone who wants to harmony look I
understand there are physical
differences in regards to their physical
differences or not that person has a gun
I don't who's winning
and so talking to women what I wanted
about that that's when you really that's
when I was really able to get people to
start understanding and getting it
because a lot more people understand the
self-defense aspect of it versus oh the
Second Amendment guarantee guarantees
you that right type of argument yeah is
this an area where you're able to use a
little of their messaging against them
because you listen to a lot of the
messaging that's going on on college
campuses there's rape culture there's
constant rate that's represent all these
guys are just especially the white guys
they're the frat guys are coming to rape
all the women if we know there's no race
culture you're really of a real rape
culture of course memory happens of
course every why but are you able to use
that messaging against them and go
ladies if you believe that then what I'm
telling you actually make some sense
absolutely and that's why I started my
organization in powers because no one
was really talking about that on our
side I know granted kind of carries a
fairly new concept in the last 10-15
years but to go a step further of those
women who I don't have to try and you
know convince the most and saying you
know what and they meant to when I talk
to men and they would be at me and say
how dare you try to bring guns on campus
you know women blow a lot and then I
would say well don't you actually want
that woman to be able to protect
themselves from that and then I think
several times yes several times they may
because I'm a woman I'm telling them
about it and also a black woman because
they'll reuse a race card on that one as
well to say actually as a black person I
want to protect myself from that bigot
that in that scenario you're talking
about if you keep me defenseless I can't
protect myself in that scenario also as
a woman I want that option to protect
myself because you're also keeping me
defenseless in that scenario so talking
to these girls on campus sorry women on
campus and telling them that if you so
choose to have this as your tool for
self-defense you should have that right
to it they get it then regardless of
what ideology politics are who they
voted for before that liberal women you
know libertarian classical liberal
whatever Trump people burning people
I've seen every single type of girl or a
person change their minds about guns
because they see it as a self-defense
issue and people need to bring the
messaging around that versus what
they've been doing before yeah do you
fear any kind of slippery slope with all
this so that you do a campus carry and
let's say in Texas Texas you have
totally concealed carry right now okay I
can still carry all out yes and open
carry they have that now but in the
terms of campus carry is concealed
right so the open carry is like when we
see these pictures of like four guys
yeah she appeared to be rifles I got
Chipotle and it looks nice it look it
looks kind of scary that just seems kind
of scary to me may not actually no no
that is definitely scary no then what
then how do we have that conversation
and like the slippery slope part of this
where it's like alright well if everyone
can have open carry you can wander in it
to a Chipotle with a gun on your back
and you can have guns everywhere that
that's the slippery slope of we're going
to end up being just the Wild West like
we're going to go to a place where
people are going to start getting into
arguments all the time and solving it
that way you just see that as a
nonsensical starting point I you're
looking at because I don't like man the
points I'm going to make right now
point one and so the first of all the
vile less thing I will talks about
because it's funny I always hear that
especially on the left and like okay why
you actually read your history because
the Wild West was actually even more gun
control friendly because they made
everybody check their guns with the
sheriff
so does some knowledge right yeah when
you go to a town you'd have to give your
gun to the sheriff and he would make a
decision for you if you have your gun or
not so it's not the follow us is the
opposite another thing is that yeah
obviously I can't make I can't lie and
say that those people aren't doing that
I definitely don't think that's the
proper way to to get people on our side
but for the majority of the time it's
people if they're open carrying if they
are I still have yet to see very many
people do it since we've had in Texas
then they're responsible people they're
people that they don't look like they're
threatening or they're going to harm
someone do I still believe and and know
that there are people who are fearful
and they see stuff like that absolutely
me not too long ago I was the same
person and I think you have to have an
honest conversation is like look I would
have gun rights activist before I even
purchase a handgun because for a long
time I thought maybe the gun whoa does
go off you know I didn't know the
mechanics of a gun people had they're
not going to learn it just naturally
they have to know it by people educating
them and you have to be patient and stop
yelling at them in their faith and
bringing ar-fifteens in their face
saying you must I demand that you accept
my my side of thinking and talk to them
and have a conversation let them know
that you're a good human being first and
the people behind those guns are good
law-abiding citizens and then you'll
start to change people's minds on the
guns because it's not really about the
gun it's about the person so I like that
last sentence particularly because I
know that if I had a gun right now any
kind of caliber yeah I would not walk
into a school and start shooting people
I wouldn't walk into a mosque or a
temple or anywhere I wouldn't I simply
wouldn't do that because of my own
mental capacity and I don't not
following an ideology they would want me
to do that or anything of that nature
but
do you see any of this as when we have
these shootings do you see any of it on
the fault of the guns or do you always
believe it's ideology and mental health
and what at whatever else operating I
never see it as the gun I see it before
even a Wayne LaPierre made it a popular
you know a good guy with a gun type
saying I've never seen it as I've seen
as the people behind it I mean you can
use any tool to harm someone ut-austin
just a couple weeks ago how about
stabbing which is funny because they
turned it around and said well campus
carry didn't help us in that situation
well it's not about that it was about
the fact that I'm sorry it's about the
stabbing of a student with mental health
issues stabbed several people killing
one freshman yeah and a lot of
organizations a lot of news outlets said
well campus carry didn't help us in that
situation well you know that's part of
it too is that welcoming doesn't because
because it doesn't mean that everyone's
going to have a gun there automatic and
so absolutely wanted to build absolutely
but people don't see that they see
someone was killed and they see that
there are guns on campus and guns are
supposed to be the enemy there but it's
really it's about the person it's you
know we have to make sure that we are
keeping these people healthy that's
about what mental health let's just talk
about that more we don't didn't have to
be a taboo issue and I hope on our side
we'll talk more about that and we won't
be the reactionary side to the people
who are bringing it up what's let's be
the forefront and the advocates for
mental health as much as we are
advocates for for guns why not so what
kind of checks do you think are actually
legit like if you were fresh right in
the law right oh man um you know I've
always sucked the fact of campus carry I
feel like when you bring other
legislation in there and that it water
is down your argument with campus carry
especially I I don't see myself changing
my views on the fact that concealed
carry is a good way to go when it comes
to going on college campus maybe because
we still have a whole lot of thursdays
to convince before that and it has
helped to say look there are these
checks in place if you are afraid of
student
having a gun on campus what the law that
the state says it's okay so I know you
about your big fan of state
administrative office so at least
refresh senator scenario - its help it's
helped I will say that so I will say
that yeah right now I mean I'm not open
carry when I work at a gun range I don't
carry the gun range am I totally fine
with that yeah definitely am I afraid of
someone else who has one no but I do
know that there's a fear behind that and
so let's just be smart about it whether
let's take back that phrase common sense
and bring it on our side and use common
sense with with something yeah so what
about it just in the more broad sense
about access to guns like are you okay
with that being a state right you know
whatever the background check is and all
that Jeannette I'll be kicked back to
the states should it be the more local
and anything like that you know and I
know that they do things here in
California differently like my border
Johnny yeah Weezer's have it outlook on
life so yeah so I let this all be like
Texas Lucy you know I just I see I think
you know as a you know libertarian
leaning person I do believe going bring
it back to the states and then having
that issue that right - that is
important
same thing with campus carry I think it
should ever become a federal issue with
campus carry I think it's been good as a
state-by-state issue
yes it's harder but man I think right
now having the background checks and
making sure the people behind them are
law-abiding citizens is important but
again it doesn't matter on the gun
control side they'll take those wall
buying citizens and make them demons
regardless the befel we're seeing right
now is that these law-abiding citizens
that statistically have not have hurt
less people than the general public are
demonized every time these mass
shootings and these things happens in
gun-free zones right oh yeah I am gonna
- so are we having the same problems
with the gun discussion that we're
having with terrorism discussion in that
we only talk about it right after
something horrible happened I'm sorry so
that we can never have an either then
they'll say well now's not the time to
talk about it
many people start screaming Nevada
because they're they're upset about dead
people which is completely legit exactly
but that in the moment between we're not
good at talking about anything actually
that's when people just start living
their lives and doing everything so we
go from crisis to crisis to crisis which
certainly doesn't help you know calm
argument regardless of what side you're
on on this and we're having that issue
even now in the age of Trump is that
people mean look at the gun industry ask
anybody right now and see if gun sales
are down and ammunition is down because
first of all people thought Hillary is
gonna be President and so went up and
then now it's down because people think
oh it's okay Jim its Trump is he's with
NRA everything's gonna be fine and they
become complacent and so it's actually
harder for the people like me who are
advocates to say no no no this is not
going to be forever and if you are
complacent now especially on the state
level which is where all this stuff is
happening I mean you're seeing this
right now in California where the states
are really making those decisions and
then say we get someone who's completely
on the left on next time it's already
eight years behind so you have to
continue that fight even when it's not
sexy when you think that on the federal
level we're good
that's actually the most dangerous time
because people are not looking and
people are able to get in in ways that
no one keeps him up accountable so
that's the scary part where do you think
Trump fits into all this because the NRA
loved him he doesn't mean like me as a
real gun person one way or another I
mean he's a New Yorker so I'm just a guy
too
I mean maybe he had security I'm sure he
has security that walks around the gun
obviously now he's a Secret Service but
like his whole life he lived in the
liberal bubble of New York City I don't
think you I don't like it just doesn't
strike me as a pet issue of his but the
NRA loved him I think he's said the
right things for that group do you have
a real sense of what he really believes
in it uh you know I really think he's
legitimate about and that's why you know
I said people get mad me but it was
about pro-life issues and being able to
defend myself and I felt like on those
two key issues for me that he was going
to be strong on them and so far he's
been very strong on both those issues
I don't see him changing fiscal issues a
budget and health care now that I'm
always open to debating him about
because I don't think he's ever ever was
an advocate for for limited government
in that sense but those two issues I
feel are in many one he was much more of
a Democrat absolutely although he right
now he is chopping a lot of the federal
amount that we're spending on a lot of
programs yeah as well that yeah we'll
see exactly we'll see yeah well let's
talk about the pro-life thing for a
minute
so I'm pro-choice but I view abortion as
a as a horrible choice that I know
several women that have had abortions
nobody takes it lightly you know
unfortunately a lot of the messaging I
think that you get from the far less
known abortion is they fetishized it
into almost being something cool
olia and Don says that she wishes she
had an abortion that type of stuff
yeah really I mean I'm not making that
up and you see I see a lot of videos on
YouTube that have you know hundreds of
thousands if not millions of views where
they're just talking about it in such a
casual sort of fun way there was that
video of the girl who worked at an
abortion clinic who had an abortion and
she liked videotapes whole thing and
there was a lot of questions as to
whether she purposely got pregnant or
just found me I mean there's all kinds
of crazy crazy stuff I gave it as just
as a horrific ly impossible existential
question and that my go-to here
ironically would be a little bit like
what got Tommy Laird in some hot water
which is that it shouldn't be the
government deciding what you should do
with your body
so I'll just hand it to you from there
yeah well there's so much on that I just
know are swollen I know it's all over
that is the one thing but but you know
actually I can make a really good
argument and why libertarians have is
that if you're the government's there to
protect life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness I mean you don't have any of
that without life so that's a big side
with me is that yeah you need to protect
life and I think that's why people are
kind getting away from that are going to
the argument of wind life begins right
and that's why it's shifted that way
because more people are thinking really
right I mean you can't have life without
I mean if you're going to do that so but
I mean I've always been a gangrenous in
that space though because I think back
to healthy argument AB like we had you
two want a verse or scientists but we
could sit here and say you know I think
for the first month that you can have an
abortion and I think it's a hard choice
but acceptable yeah there's at least
some room to if you believe it's
conception then we can't we can't quite
that they're on that that's okay but at
least there's some talking point there
right absolutely
well you know there is definitely
talking points and I won't be honest I
I'm still trying to figure out what I
believe I will say probably right now I
still believe that it comes to no
conception that life starts there but
you know I'm still evolving and we can
see the last eight years that might be
have changed and I'm and that's the
thing I'm open to many things but I will
say well that's approach emotional
garibaldi birth yeah we'll be there yeah
it would be alive for me to say
otherwise but I will say it is primarily
emotional for me I not that you know
I've had to deal with that personally
but life is something so important to me
I mean women and children are something
so important to me and I just believe
that if we're not protecting them
because they are you know vulnerable
they don't have a voice then what are we
really doing is we can't protect those
who don't have a voice without that
students or that that's those who are on
born so I will say in that regards I
believe that the government should
protect that that right the right life
so if we do hypothetical yeah if you
know scientists could you know come down
with the study that says well we know
actually that it's not consumption but
it's six weeks in something magical
happens and that's when life begins you
think you could possibly I'm really not
trying to thin you yeah I'm just trying
to because you're saying it's about
feeling you're you're feeling right now
so if they came to me a lot like I'm a
very large table feelings and emotions
but if they could lay down something
that said you know this is what we've
been able to prove do you think that
could be enough to shift you you know I
don't know it would have to be when it
gets to there because it'd be a lot of
stuff you know I'm I'm a born-again
Christian and that was seven years ago
and so that's very important to me and I
just know that that's something that you
should not be advocating for now do I
really think it's really that question I
think we'll have other if even that
happens that there's so many people who
are going to say well no okay people so
our six weeks but anything after that
and then people want the right to
continue on I think that argument is not
going to end but yeah I really can't I
can't say whether or not if the science
is there if it's going to insert that
six weeks if I change my mind because of
that how about we'll do this again
that's a good idea ten months then we'll
see okay there you go hey well that
sounds like I just shift my mind my
decisions in Miami I'm so much yesterday
okay we'll continue with more than Tony
and her political spectrum today yeah
there's a movie there yes so as a small
L libertarian there's the pro licen then
put you in a different tough spot
because you don't want the government to
then have to pay for a child but if a
woman that is you know poverty-stricken
or whatever can't afford to have this
child then the government says well
abortion is illegal so you're going to
have to have this child does the state
then have any responsibility to help
them you can't like that idea as a
libertarian right well I don't even get
that so I hope someone who advocates for
any personal responsibility to say that
there's only two choices there is that
oh that the government says you can't
have an abortion so therefore it has to
also take care of your children
we don't do for anybody else no I mean
that's not I mean there's there's
instance after instance where you're not
doing that so just to say that if that
scenario happened that we some we have
to also at that time take care of that
child
of course I think there should be some
type of safety net and you're mostly the
trainees believe that it's
long it is to the point where it keeps
someone from having that responsibility
for their own life and the life that
they choose or the life that they have
and they take care of no I mean I think
that's where the community should come
in where you know the places of faith or
what other state that you have the
people around you should be helping with
that and I think that's what we advocate
for as well but your hands is that no
one said that the government is supposed
to be taking care of us in that in that
way even when it comes to abortion yeah
so you basically see it is a false
choice and regulation yeah and to say
that has the two scenarios and that's it
you choose one and if you're not your
note and all of a cheering I don't
believe it
yeah yeah all right well this hour is
completely a wrap this thing in a nice
bow for all the people out there that
are having their own political evolution
and I think you've been very frank and
honest here and all that about your own
continuing evolution which is a
beautiful thing and that's what I try to
bring to this every week what would you
say is the most important thing for
someone that wants to get in the fight
even if they disagree with you
politically you would think that and
watch this for an hour and go man she's
bonkers for my hair but what would you
say to them about just like having that
moment and being able to you know talk
about things that your parents may not
like or that your family maybe into or
any of that I would say I mean fight on
I mean that's not so like like I swear
I'm 27 guys like I don't sound rough so
like I'm in my 80s or something but no
seriously it's going to be hard I mean
if you really want to make a difference
having the conversations that are needed
most people are not going to do that
keep keep at it I mean because those
people who believe they can make a
difference are going to make a
difference we see it already today so
keep on and there other people doing the
same thing you're not alone but it's
important we need that we need out of
the country especially now so all right
well it's absolutely flew by I didn't
look down on one I'm impressive are you
awesome
and burying presents more on Antonia
check out her website at Antonia okafor
calm
[Music]